IMPROVED FOR BLUE-COLLAR WORKERS
THAT CONTINUES TO DO
ASTONISHINGLY WELL ARE
EMPLOYEES OF THE FEDERAL
$66 MILLION PER HOUR, AND
$524 MILLION PER DAY.
GREAT PAYCHECK.
AND AT 78 FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
AGENCIES, THE AVERAGE EMPLOYEE
COMPENSATION EXCEEDED $100,000
IN 2016.
SO FOR MORE, LET'S BRING IN FROM
CHICAGO THE CEO AND FOUNDER OF
OPEN THE BOOKS, DASHES OUT YOUR
NAME?
>> YES.
>> Katie: LET'S GO THROUGH
THESE NUMBERS ONE MORE TIME.
PAYING FEDERAL EMPLOYEES FOR
THEIR TIME?
>> WELL, FEDERAL EMPLOYEES, THE
BUREAUCRACY, IS PAID A MILLION
DOLLARS A MINUTE.
AUDITED THEM, OUR TEAM OF
AUDITORS FOUND THAT THERE ARE
30,000 FEDERAL BUREAUCRATS SET
OUT IN EVERY GOVERNOR OF THE 50
THAT IS THEIR SALARY.
WE ALSO FOUND THAT IF YOU ARE A
HIGHLY COMPENSATED FEDERAL
SALARY, AND BONUS, A NUMBER OF
FEDERAL EMPLOYEES HAVE INCREASED
GOVERNMENT.
CAN THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
FUNCTION WITHOUT FILLING ALL
FOR TAXPAYERS?
>> SO THE PRESIDENT HAS LEAD ON
THIS WITH HIS OWN PAYROLL AT THE
WHITE HOUSE.
HE IS RUNNING A LEANER PAYROLL
THAN AT THE SAME POINT DURING
THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION.
HE IS DOWN 100 POSITIONS AND WE
FORECAST THAT WOULD SAVE
TAXPAYERS $20 MILLION OVER THE
COURSE OF HIS FOUR YEARS.
THE FIRST LADY IS ALSO LEADING
ON THIS.
SHE HAS A PAYROLL OF FIVE
EMPLOYEES VERSUS 24 EMPLOYEES,
AS FORMER FIRST LADY
MICHELLE OBAMA HAD.
HERE'S THE POINT, KATIE.
EVERYBODY WATCHING THE POINT
TONIGHT NEEDS TO COME TO OPEN
THE BOOKS.COM.
WE HAVE MAPPED THE 2 MILLION
OWN ZIP CODE, A SMALL PIECE OF
THE SWAMP, A SMALL PIECE OF THE
FEDERAL BUREAUCRACY, ALL OF US
NEED TO GIVE IT OVERSIGHT AND
WE NEED TO ASK OUR MEMBER OF
CONGRESS WHAT THEY ARE DOING TO
SQUEEZE OUT THE BLOW TO THE
FEDERAL BUREAUCRACY.
>> Katie: IT'S NOT JUST INSIDE
THE BELTWAY, IT BLEEDS ITSELF
OUT INTO THE REST OF THE
COUNTRY, AS WELL.
YOU TALK ABOUT OVERSIGHT AND
TRANSPARENCY.
THE NUMBERS ON BONUSES ARE
ABSOLUTELY INCREDIBLE.
330,000 BONUSES, TOTAL FEDERAL
BONUSES, $1.5 BILLION.
NONE OF THAT IS DISCLOSED,
ESSENTIALLY, OR IS A VERY SMALL
PORTION.
>> RIGHT, ONLY ONE-THIRD OF THE
TOTAL BONUSES ARE ACTUALLY
DISCLOSED.
THAT IS A REAL PROBLEM.
IT'S A A TRANSPARENCY PROBLEM.
BECAUSE THE UNIONS, THE FEDERAL
BONUSES, THAT IS $1.1 BILLION
WORTH OF PERFORMANCE
BONUSES, AREN'T DISCLOSED.
THEY AREN'T DISCLOSED TO BECOME
OF THE PEOPLE COME ON WHO GETS
WHAT IN TERMS OF PERFORMANCE
BONUS.
WE HAVE SHOWED THAT SMALL
AGENCY IN SAN FRANCISCO,
CALIFORNIA, THEY ONLY EMPLOY 300
PEOPLE, BUT THREE OUT OF THE
FOUR LARGEST BONUSES LAST YEAR,
THEY ARE NOT CURING CANCER, THEY
ARE A LAND MANAGEMENT
ORGANIZATION AND THE TOP BONUS
IN THE ENTIRE FEDERAL SYSTEM
WENT TO THEIR HUMAN RESOURCE
MANAGER.
HOW IS IT THAT THIS IS
SEGMENT, MANY OF THESE
BUREAUCRATS ARE BEING PAID AS
MUCH OR MORE THAN ELECTED
SENATORS.
I MEAN, HOW DOES THAT PROCESS
WORK AND HOW DID THEY GET TO
THOSE NUMBERS?
BONUSES BUT IT'S ALSO PERKS.
AND YOU GET YOUR THREE YEAR
ANNIVERSARY, YOU STAND IN LINE
TO GET EIGHT AND A HALF WEEKS OF
PAID TIME OFF.
OF PAID TIME OFF.
$22 BILLION.
>> Katie: SOUNDS LIKE
EUROPEAN-STYLE LIVING AND
WORKING TO ME, INSIDE THE
BELTWAY AND OUTSIDE AS YOU HAVE
POINTED OUT.
THE 2018 ELECTIONS ARE COMING
UP, REPUBLICANS HAVE BEEN
RUNNING FOR YEARS ON CUTTING
SPENDING.
SPENDING CUTS ARE ALWAYS VERY
DIFFICULT BUT IF YOU COULD
ADVISE POLITICIANS AND
WHAT WOULD YOU SAY TO THEM IN
ABUSED IN THIS WAY?
>> TWO CUTS FOR $2 BILLION,
REALLY QUICKLY.
THEN, KATIE, THIS IS BIPARTISAN,
FEDERAL P.R. OFFICERS.
TOTAL COST, AND THAT SHOULD BE